seller Fields days as a nuclear power
station are long gone now it's a storage
site for highly radioactive waste held
in aging bunkers but scientists working
for the government believe that
cumbria's Coast were another site in
Lincolnshire could offer a long-term
solution with waste buried in rocks up
to a kilometer under the seabed so it
looks a bit more pleasing to the
environment and they're talking to
communities to win their support it is
important that there is you know
economic growth in the area and this
would be a major you know source for
local people I think doing the right
thing in terms of engaging the community
early stages but I think if they keep
going the way they're going that is
positive
radioactive waste will be taken into a
vast Warren of tunnels by train
heavy-duty canisters would be sealed
into the Bedrock plugged with Clay to
keep our water and the whole complex
sealed over when full the construction
is years off
the government is planning a new
generation of nuclear reactors but
already highly radioactive waste is
piling up with nowhere to go while the
long-term planet is to bury it deep
underground it relies on a community
saying yes and if they all say no then
what
we live here in Drag
so we're where we already have an
existing nuclear waste repository some
local residents do have doubts this
retired science teacher fares
underground water and the complex
geology in Cumbria are too much of a
risk they all know that the geology is
much better in the east of the country
where they could build a gdf that's big
enough for all the stuff they want to
put down it and they could build it
quicker
cheaper and better over there
Finland has already built a geological
tomb for waste with overwhelming support
from local residents and the UK's
nuclear waste agency says it has years
of consultation ahead to win people over
if we were to be unsuccessful in the
sighting program then it would be
government for government to reflect on
a way forward but you know
internationally this is a technological
solution which is being demonstrated we
have confidence that this is a safe
endpoint for radioactive waste
management
radioactive waste is nuclear power's
unavoidable Legacy finding a solution
will ultimately come down to public
trust in the science Thomas More Sky
News in Cumbria